[Music]
google cloud's network intelligence
center offers several tools and modules
that enable you to
diagnose and troubleshoot connectivity
issues
monitor real-time performance metrics
and visualize network health
proactively detect network problems or
misconfigurations by providing insights
about firewall rules
in this video you will learn how to
create and run connectivity tests to an
external https load balancer and
interpret the results in both a
successful and failing scenario
you may be wondering what is
connectivity tests and how does it help
you
well connectivity test is one of the key
diagnostic tools in the network
intelligence center
it enables you to check the connectivity
by verifying whether a request can
travel successfully between network
endpoints
the endpoint is a source or a
destination of network traffic such as
compute engine virtual machine
google kubernetes engine cluster
load balancer forwarding rule or an ip
address on the internet
it checks reachability by analyzing your
network configuration and
in certain use cases by sending pro
packets
we will now learn how exactly the
connectivity test works
connectivity tests traces a simulated
packet from an external host to a
virtual ip address for an external https
load balancer
notice the tcp connection from the
external host terminates at the proxy
for the external https load balancer
after this step the external https load
balancer initiates a new tcp connection
to a vm acting as the load balances back
end
in this example
the connectivity test configuration
analysis has three traces
this is because it creates one trace for
each possible path to the three load
balancer back ends
the connectivity test does this because
it validates only configurations not the
live data plane
note for the actual data plane network
traffic the load balancing algorithm
chooses a vm instance for each back-end
connection
one of the key features of the
connectivity test is that its
configuration analysis supports tracing
simulated packets
to all types of google cloud load
balances
now it's time for a quick demo
let's create a connectivity test with an
external https load balancer forwarding
rule ip as the destination
go to the connectivity test page in the
cloud console
click create connectivity test
choose a suitable protocol in our
example we will select the tcp protocol
under source select the ip address from
the drop down menu and specify the ipres
from an external client
under destination select the ip address
from the drop down menu and specify the
ip address of the external https load
balancer
leave the check box for this is an ip
address used in gcp cleared
set the destination port as 80 if your
load balancer is listening only for http
requests if you want to listen for https
request then set the port as 443
click create this creates the test and
runs it
all right the test is completed
let's learn how to interpret the result
of the connectivity test
this table here shows the traces for all
the three back-end vms the trace 0 is
auto-selected you can view the trace for
a particular vm by clicking on the
specific trace
let's analyze the trace 0 which is on
the right hand panel
great the test was successful
this result demonstrates that a
simulated packet from an external ip
address could successfully reach the
load balancers back in vm instances
this indicates that all the google cloud
resources
associated with the external https load
balancer namely the forwarding rule
the load balancer back-ends
the proxy connection
the vpc firewall rules are all
configured correctly
let's now look at another connectivity
test trace that failed
hmm
the analysis shows the packets could be
dropped
this is because the vpc network's
ingress firewall rules are not allowing
the traffic to the load balancer
back-ends
thus the ends are unreachable from load
balances proxy
to fix this a firewall rule needs to be
added to allow the connections from load
balancer proxy to the backend virtual
machines
refer to this documentation for more
information
for more information on connectivity
tests for load balancers check out this
documentation thanks for watching
[Music]
you